fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby old school old school team
let me explain something to you
everybody who's young some days don't
work out that's what happens in life
it's called entropy let me explain
something to you okay you're driving in
your car you want to get somewhere in
life you want to get somewhere okay and
then what happens is your car breaks
down now you're in a rusting piece of
machinery and you still got to get to
point a you got to get to point a but
now you got a thousand ways that could
you could get there and a thousand
things and get in your way Asian drivers
yes so they say that they say that they
say that that negative emotion negative
emotion
it happens when your goals are blocked
and positive emotion means when you have
a simple Pathway to your desired goals
man shut up you know what I'm saying
dude
and right now I hit you no hold on our
car broke down
no your car broke down my car is fine
our car broke down no you're supposed to
pick me up and your car broke down so I
got a mine and I still made it you told
me to get the Fiat and I said I don't
know about these Italian cars and you
said shut up like you just did and I go
but and you go shut up it was like when
I said don't Sprint without warming up
you might pop your hat shut up shut up
and you blew both and I didn't get put
to point a I said I don't want to get
into Fiat you said shut up just get it
and then I got in the car and then
you're like ah [__] we broke down
sure yeah kind of so what do we do now
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna give you a
copy of Jocko's complete ownership you
gotta take complete ownership you have
to you got to take complete honors I
feel like everything you're dodging this
right now you guys you're supposed to
have a guest on you gave him the wrong
address right I didn't give anybody the
wrong no you assumed that they had the
address because I want to slap your warm
old mouth giving them the address I know
but
complete ownership man right Jocko the
missions broke down you know emissions
broke down at the bottom you know what
Jocko said you can't do it all
[Applause]
that's
this is the opposite of chocolate and
you know what I can't do it have you
read the book I'm halfway through I was
right on the plane and he's right no you
sound like the businessman because
they're a businessman he was like this
big time successful businessman there's
like something miscommunication and he
goes to him and he goes so what's going
on he goes I mean I tell them what to do
it's just not getting done and goes okay
whose fault is that he's like well it's
Jerry he's like it's not because who's
in charge of Jerry yes he's like me he's
like okay so if Jerry's not doing it
right that's right who's it on is that
is and the guy kept going Jerry's like
no bad it's on you because Jocko's like
so for instance like the book starts off
he's like he's on submission and there's
miscommunication and it was Blue on Blue
Fire which means Friendly Fire they're
shooting at each other because of
miscommunication and then the sergeants
come in like whose [__] fault is this
whose fault is in front of all the
troops and Jocko in his head he was like
all right well this this
miscommunication there there's a million
reasons why it messed up and he just
goes and he thought he was gonna get
fired lose his job he goes it's my fault
and they're like what he's like it's my
fault I'm the guy who was in charge of
this Mission and I didn't make sure that
they had the information to make sure
that they realized there weren't
friendlies in there it's it you know
what it's on me 100 and you did get
fired because they're like holy [__]
that's a badass that's what you want
nothing could be truer read that book
nothing could be true about taking
extreme ownership but you refused you're
the businessman who goes it's Jerry's
fault I'm going to take extreme
ownership
right there you're the opposite of Jaco
I just can't do it
I love that I just it's funny yeah I
just got it's funnier I can't just play
and I can't even do a little of it
sometimes like I'm just like generally I
suck at a lot of stuff like I'll try to
do six things and I'm just like well
that fell apart three out of six go well
that's you know I love tennis right yeah
and and the there are there are three
guys in tennis that never lose yeah so
everybody who plays tennis no matter how
good they are they always lose yeah you
know you lose way more than you play and
then there are three guys in the five
that the two greatest three the greatest
to ever live Roger Federer
um um Rafa Nadal and uh you see and uh
joke
Novak Djokovic
they're so [__] good and when you see
people playing them they've trained they
trained they work so hard they're six
they're playing they're hitting the ball
and then somehow somehow even with a
foot injury that [__] dog comes back
from two two it's so much better they
are at tennis than you and you just see
them you see the best in the world go
like this the guys who's number four
ownership complete she goes he just goes
he's sitting in his chair like this and
he's like I couldn't yeah I took all the
ownership yeah I got it but it's so
funny enough to take ownership so funny
I can't it does work though like to
Jocko's credit like you know I have to
run a business and when things mess up
and you know it's not your fault and
you're dealing with you know whoever
YouTube or bent pixel and they're like
what happened with this and if you're
just like that's on me the team goes oh
thank God he took the brunt of it it's
his business he takes the brunt of it so
people feel better about it well like
stuff to do because if you know somebody
[__] up you want to be like no no I
know hey dude I told you to post that
last week and like oh I forgot if you if
I mean unpack it unpack it it's on me
unpack it like this if the thumbnails
suck if the clips suck if people aren't
watching you there might be a thousand
Reasons at the end of the day nobody out
there cares no what they don't nobody
cares bottom line all that matters is
are are the numbers there and are people
listening or watching or buying your
product or whatever it might be that's
all that matters well same with like I
mean just stop on this all time he'll
get calls from certain Comics that tear
into them when they don't sell tickets I
tell Joseph I've never done that I told
Justin I go have I ever done two because
you're one a few Comics I've never done
I go if I'm banking on you promoting my
shows I'm already losing I so just lined
up for me I handle the rest I don't get
them at the club I mean if they misspell
my name or some [__] or if they have no
no like if the Poster's wrong like from
last year that's that's just me being
detailed drives me nuts my favorite or
if I get there it's rare it hasn't
happened last four years if I get this
is Brent job UFC I'm like no what are
you doing yeah I'm always coming to
watch videos family members are friends
would be like who aren't in the business
to be like show businessman acting so
unfair I don't it's just not fair it's a
and it's like it is fair well it might
it doesn't matter if it's fair nothing's
Fair it doesn't matter that has no
relevance to anything if you if I didn't
make it as an actor it's my fault yeah
not either I wasn't good enough didn't
work hard enough didn't work smart
enough Whatever It Is Well the people
that blame it on in uh Jocko talks about
this in his book like and he talks about
like in Hollywood like people like oh I
didn't make it because I didn't get this
this opportunity or this and this is
this it's like yeah I guess you can
chalk it up to that sure or those salty
Comics I'm not selling tickets for this
reason this is it's like you listed
every reason that doesn't include
yourself
the best part is you can be right and
you're still wrong you're like you're
right all that shit's a great sure that
sucks like I never got the break I had
an act teacher he'd have an actor and
the actor wasn't working and the actor
things weren't going well it's the same
[__] and then he'd give them a critique
and the actor was usually smart and
would come back with something and the
teacher would go Hey listen stop you're
gonna talk me out of my critique you're
going to convince me that you're right
and either way I didn't like that movie
it I didn't like it you can tell me a
thousand things but I can't
that you're going to talk me out of my
[__] critique you're paying me to be
right shut the [__] up yeah it's
definitely a skill set to like running a
company being a boss like make sure
everyone's comfortable but my my phone
doesn't work dude
I my phone isn't working is that Apple's
problem or is that a Brian County
[__] Apple they they jammed up the
signal see and I just hold my phone up
ask me ask me like how I got the address
wrong how'd you how did you mess up the
address so big J didn't come
son what has nothing to do with that's
my baby hey maybe that's why it's not
working you dropped it I can't
I just can't yeah follow through
what up details I pushed the whole day
for 1 30 and then you messed up the
address
I'm so glad I've worked on myself and I
I'm not lashing out physically anymore
hey I've taken steps of complete
ownership of not being a serial killer
are you taking folks are you taking
completely I want to kill you in a way
like maybe it's your fault too because
it's half your show
ah foxy here we go see there you go but
it's funny but see I like funny this is
funny no ownership funny no ownership is
hilarious are you are you putting all
ownership on me this time yes
but we're this is our show you it ran we
have a guest a guy who books guests and
you went I got it he took ownership I
hear you he took ownership I'm [__]
the guest I took off and you didn't use
the guy that we paid to book the guests
and then they hit the wrong address
[Applause]
why the [__] didn't you check on you
know what I'm halfway through Jocko's
book you're not there yet you ready
you're not there go watch you ready
you're right
it's on me
I should have made sure that you said in
the right address and we've only been
here over a year thank you hey hey in
the address that Brian sent them
was in Playa Vista we haven't been in
six years
it's my fault I didn't send that address
hey it's on me Hey Big Jay it's um
it's on me hold on completely ownership
it's complete ownership complete
ownership
is it is it oh is it partial ownership
or is it extreme ownership is it is the
book partial ownership it's extreme
ownership are you taking extreme
ownership right now are you taking
partial ownership is this your show
extreme is this half your show someone
said more why the [__] didn't you make
sure that big J had our address because
you were dealing with texting personally
but it's my fault it's on me I'm glad
you're [__] I hope I made you proud
Jocko book is penetrating oh it's
working oh I feel good about it too okay
oh I feel good oh thank you you know it
feels so you know I was in a class with
a Scientologist so my class initially
and acting class was a was run by a
Scientologist no correct I know and the
teachers scientologists and a lot of
people in the class yeah but you had
nothing so watch this so if people were
sick
if you are sick
didn't matter what the disease was could
be really serious it could be whatever
tell me tell me just cough and stuff
watch this
what's going on I don't feel I mean I
don't feel okay just feel okay it might
be allergic I can't teach that what's
going on
what's going on in front of the whole
class oh oh this is in front of 100
people watch this wait wait what's going
on I feel a little you feel you feel why
because I I didn't you didn't sleep good
that's why you think you got sick this
is amazing are you you think it's
because you didn't sleep good are you
gonna tell me next there was a draft hey
would they just they're a draft would
they never come back oh no well now
watch this this would go they'd be so
bad they'd go like this they go
you think that's what causes sickness I
just want to know
did you say you have something to do
with it that's what it was you know what
they they're they're taking extreme
ownership of sickness they that's what
they did they'd go what in your life is
not congruent that is making you so in
Scientology don't their sign of
disrespect is slapping you know that's
why the Will Smith slapped Chris Rock I
didn't know that yeah like you know the
guy yeah Scientologist Will Smith is yep
he says they aren't but you see how you
went like this
because you weren't quite sure because I
think they denounced I don't think he is
well they
yeah long denied allegations they
remember everyone denies it hey hey hey
hey that's I know they're in it no hey
hey b hey sure they're not I mean I've
been to events but I'm not a
Scientologist
hmm
but the one of the signs that one of the
things in Scientology is they slap so
like I promise that sort of thing so
that guy who looked like Tom Cruise
remember the leader he was missing his
wife has been missing he's missing now
there's so many videos of him slapping
people it's fantastic who Tom Cruise no
the the little small who looks like Tom
Cruise oh yeah he was so angry oh yeah
but they slap they don't punt they slap
nothing more disrespectful they need to
[__] get the Diaz brothers on that
[__] they can't find uh him no he's
missing because his wife is missing as
well yeah well he's got a lot of people
are trying to sue him oh Scientology
goes we'll make it go away I just can't
and you know what again this goes back
to taking complete ownership yeah yeah
of
making people Miss um yeah so they would
say if you're sick you are it's it's a
cop-out
and they're right
oh dude it's a good way to live right
it's a good way to live because the
alternative is if you don't understand
somebody if you're gonna blame somebody
for anything what happens is it nothing
gets done nothing gets done I'm telling
you listen I love Jocko reading that
book and I've tried to implement that I
go my bad but even with in my at home my
life like if Tiger has some issue or
whatever I have an issue my bad that's
on me that's right because there's no
you take ownership and there's really
that's it that's it there's no argument
as long as you understand my bad I
[__] up that's right you understand
that my bad here's the other thing bad
things are going to happen to you no
matter what okay that that's just how
everybody's life is that's nature okay
know that please know that bad things
gonna happen sometimes it can be really
bad what are you gonna do as a result of
that just complain about it not taking
ownership isn't gonna move the ball I
can't remember the book there was a guy
who got mugged got the [__] beat out of
him he he was in the hospital for three
months in New York City he wrote a
letter he wrote a book while he was in
jail in bed he wrote a book that ended
up being a best seller he wrote a letter
in the New York Times extreme ass woman
thanking the mugger for [__] him up
because damn different perspective never
would have written the book and the mug
was like yeah I need 10 [__] lemons to
Lemonade you fox turning chicken [__] in
a chicken soup Brandon February I'm in
Edmonton Alberta I'm at the comic strip
February 23 24. bring your coat yup
Nashville Tennessee Zanies March two
three and four come get some New York
New York's Tony Hall Sony Hall still
take us one show March 11th get your
tickets Brian kellen.com then West Nyack
New York Levity Live March 16 17 18.
Brandon where you going to be I'm in
Naples this week or next weekend this
weekend we're doing fight companion Joe
Rogan's on JRE not thick boy with the
original crew Eddie Bravo Rogan myself
and Brian count UC 284 companion Going
Down live on JRE YouTube that will be
fully uploaded to Spotify but next week
next Thursday Friday Saturday Naples
coming off the hook Naples Florida 16th
through the 18th Bakersfield one night
only February 23rd almost sold out Brea
California one night only had to cancel
the Saturday March 3rd two shows one
night with a very special guest there in
Brea California March 3rd March 4th we
have a cal basketball campaign for Jon
Jones big fight and then Oklahoma City
is March 9th through 11th Tacoma March
23rd through the 25th get your tickets
at fatkz.com or thick boy.com this show
is brought to you by better help by the
way that the thing about betterhelp is
you can find a therapist we love them
yeah without sitting in a waiting room
you can you can be paired up with a
licensed therapist in under 48 hours and
you know there's no shame in sometimes
needing somebody to talk to if you're a
guy like me we don't call each other we
you know they we don't talk that's why
therapy can be really oh therapist think
about all therapy I've done I didn't
kill you today this is true thank God if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a a great options
convenient flexible affordable and
entirely online just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist switch therapist
anytime you want if you're not feeling
the vibe no additional charge if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there look at me
betterhelp.com fighter today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com fighter there's no shame in
this everybody needs somebody to talk to
us I get older I start to realize how
important it is to talk to a licensed
therapist somebody who's been there
somebody who understands you because you
might think your problems are unique to
you they're not they're not we're all
dealing with it that can truly help you
betterhelp.com fighter
look on it.com slash fa tell them about
that best new trophies on the planet um
f-a-t-k is where you go if you want
no nootropic a nootropic like Alpha
Brain you can have Alpha Brain instant
you can have Alpha Brain Black Label
which is what you take I love Black
Label I like the focus shot too I use
the folk shot before I do stand up I do
the Black Label some of the podcast
literally some of the most effective
people I've ever met
Alpha Brain now maybe you have trouble
sleeping maybe you need some melatonin
spray maybe you need some diet
maybe you need some krill oil some fish
oil what if I need protein you got
protein over there protein dude I got
the best protein on them yeah whey
protein plant-based protein monk fruit I
got stuff that doesn't raise your your
glycemic level we've got MCT oils if
you're keto we got fat Butters
supplements on planet Earth they are
Relentless and if you don't like it if
you don't feel an effect they will give
you your money back again with Alpha
Brain if you don't like it money back
guarantee that's how confident they are
You're Gonna Love Alpha Brain all you
got to do is go to audit.com
f-a-t-k and you get 10 off Alpha Brain
shroom tech viru tech everything
glutamine creatine everything best
supplements on the freaking planet on
it.com
f-a-t-k 10 off everything all right
let's get back to program chicken I like
this morning this morning I wake up my
son goes daddy one of the fishes is
swimming upside down sleeping damn
another fish dead he's not sleeping
buddy for acidity
I take owners I take ownership white
egg you've got to keep the white ick out
of your [__] yeah you get stressed
out and their immune systems go down
when you constantly change the water
oh and then what about the lights yeah
that's why the maximum you can have that
you know this is balls even fish life if
you turn you know when you go to
aquariums the lights are so bright all
the time so you can see the fish yeah it
actually shortens the life of the fish I
bet the maximum light they should have
is six hours okay so I'll turn the
lights on on Dim when I leave when I
come home if I want to watch them drink
my coffee chill I've turned the lights
on for maybe 20 minutes and then they're
off they keep you calm but the more oh
they should keep you calm nothing better
right until that
200 flower had passed away this morning
he did he was a little one and I put him
in a tank with a big Oscar and Oscar
went cool story you two hundred dollars
my man paid 200. well you got all these
cool looking fins I'm gonna try those
out because they look like Jolly
Ranchers you Jolly Rancher my tank and I
like Jolly Rancher and there's no you're
a little guy I'm not gonna hurt you oh
there's none of that you don't realize
how big of [__] fishes are fish kill
fish fish eat fish off this crime dude
if fish on Fish crime the ocean right
now that 50 of the fish out there are
having a terrible time every fish out
there is having a bad time that's why we
everything I'll tell you what I'm
talking about I'm shooting for you when
I go I've got uh she goes I see you
really into fish oh yeah she goes those
poor fish I'm like put them in the ocean
see how it goes see how that goes so
they can dodge great whites and killer
whales [__] or she can just or they can
live with me and I feed them every
single day take care of them I pet some
of them the ones that want to be petted
you dodge every fish you dodge every
[__] fish literally you dodge every
fish that is bigger than you did you see
my octopus teacher
I can't believe you didn't see this
you're octopus teacher it's on Netflix
he's a guy who went swimming Oh I
thought you were here well a teacher
who's I thought you're an octopus and
you hired a teacher
find out about it now I don't have I've
been talking about fish tanks that
people hate for how many weeks and
you're just let me know you have a
teacher who teaches you how to take care
of this octopus no I don't this guy this
is why you should never eat calamari
every single day he he would go into
this frigid water in South Africa and
hang out with this octopus and
all an octopus does is shapeshift and
try to stay alive
and he may be having an okay time during
the day the minute the sun goes down oh
the sharks come out looking for you so
he'd hide under shells he'd bring his
shells over his body and just be like
I'm not gonna move you're holding
imagine that life anxiety oh forget it
and that's like a die in a year anyway
my fish like when my I have this like
fish fish expert named Brian come over
the house I go all of them are getting
along and goes
wait do you go to bed and what do you
mean when you leave turn out the lights
that's when it goes down I feel really
good oh they know you're not watching
and when the lights go off they get
after he goes let's see if they survive
tomorrow sure enough like last night I
have this little leopard cichlid badass
aggressive but he's smaller
there's some big boy he's responsible in
the tank he's the one that was as my son
said swimming upside down napping do you
know what you would oh no it's dead you
know what you would become addicted to
and I mean you have an addictive
personality whatever you go that that if
you got it proper if you got it properly
proper [__] in my mouth got it proper
yep if you are watching your fish tank
as somebody was breaking like and you
had poppers for your nose because and it
could happen I'm relaxed but the thing
that you don't want to do is go to don't
go to Tahiti and scuba dive and be under
the water for an hour breathing
underwater and swimming with schools of
the most beautiful as a kid that was my
job I did that as a kid I did that I
stayed under so long that I they I had
they were worried I was going to get the
bends I wouldn't come up yeah it's a
different world everything moves in slow
motion and you're like uh hopefully
we'll see stuff I saw everything
everything I saw sharks I saw huge manta
rays I I was in Finding Nemo yeah I was
literally in Finding Nemo and I saw the
Nemo fish you're a 50 year old bring up
Tahiti underwater it's a CL it's called
a clownfish yeah you would lose you
would lose your mind that's what I swam
around in all day
that that that's what I did all day
literally like that in that water
and there are no sharks see all those
black tips that's what I would do yeah
black tips I'm not scared I swam I did
that exactly I bet you she's right where
I was with all those black tips
yeah that would be me
look at that [__] yeah that looks
fantastic I was right there how tall do
you think she is
she's a nine foot eight
she's a she's a 10. yeah now I I know
you're a big Sports guy do you see
LeBron James break the record last night
I did cream
Abdul-Jabbar used to have now you know
they hate each other I didn't why did
each other why would he hate Kareem
Abdul because and like even LeBron cuss
in his post-fight speech and cream hates
all that stuff they don't like each
other and Will Chamberlain Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar because Kareem had to pass
will yeah and Wilt showed up because you
know he's showing respect but Wilton
Kareem did not like each other but
Kareem and LeBron do not like each other
no Kareem is very conservative Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar was a devout Muslim and all
that yeah so he doesn't like when he's
over in school if he's an old school now
LeBron broke his record now here's the
thing though some caveats here when
Kareem played there's no three point so
he didn't he had like one three point
made because the rules changed LeBron
passed them I think in less than he
played like less games still past him so
the argument now is like who's the best
of all time and I was listed all the
experts this morning there's that one
chubby guy who's like the LeBron expert
he's like been hanging off his nuts
since he was like 14. and he was just
saying he was like from I think he said
from 1990 like two to 1999 there's
there's never been a better basketball
player on this planet in or in sports or
Michael Jordan thank you and that was
eight years yeah but as far as from this
when we started watching when he's 14
until now 25 years and as far as
longevity a career in 25 years there's
never been a better athlete period than
LeBron James over 25 years wow he's
right he's like so the argument that
Mike joins the best of all time for sure
for those eight years there's not better
basketball player on the planet but as
far as over time it's LeBron he's right
my question though always to those guys
is this who's dick's bigger if you had I
don't know about that but if you have uh
MJ
really that's what I heard Morgan and
peace if you had
LeBron James Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan
standing in front of you and you had
your first pick most Michael Jordan it's
Michael Jordan
it is right nobody could join you who's
next
uh you see that's what I mean though
that's where you go really over Kobe
I don't know it's [__] tough it's all
weird they're all [__] great right
but here's my thing they showed that
this what bothered me so much I tweeted
this they show a picture so they show a
picture when cream or I think when
Michael Jordan hit the game win shot
over Russell and against the Jazz they
show him like his last shot then show
LeBron breaking the record when Jordan
did that whatever 97 98 there's not a
phone in sight everyone's paying
attention and it's a bunch of white
people in Utah like this they show
LeBron
the entire audience is steering through
it through their phone except for one
man
the man the suit sent on the court side
know who that is your bar no no no he
was sipping on nope Phil Knight for Nike
no [__] the Billionaire's sitting there
not on his phone just taking it in
taking it in everyone else
even his kids oh I posted I said man I
said check out uh every single person in
this Arena witnessed historic greatness
last night dot dot dot through their
phone yeah yeah there you go you ever
try to capture your child like when
you're looking at your child and they're
having an adorable moment and you're
like I gotta capture this and you try to
look through the lens you it doesn't you
miss it well I tell my girl like we'll
be at Disney and I'll tell her I go
these videos like when they're little
like you take one or two but don't act
like you're you know like we've never
been here just take it in you store it
here because the kids don't the cameras
just do it here something's not for
social media some things yeah it doesn't
need to be on camera well you can't hear
something you can't but yeah but you're
but that means we're in a simulation
we're in a simulation like everyone's
staring through their [__] phones
you're playing video games yeah like I
never understood when people are at a
concert and everyone's on their phones
like who's that for
because if I'm uh uh if I'm a subscriber
to your page who's it for so that was it
right there
you see Phil Knight
so those are our sons here's here's my
other look at everybody with their
camera yep how about the youngster ask
them for the ball though in the paint
give it up uh probably not hey get out
of here hey also get it who asked it for
it see the number 31 he's a young player
Thomas he's asking for the ball in the
post hey bro get out you know we're
trying to break records so so I have
three problems three problems with this
last night one everyone get the [__] off
your phones the most successful person
that picture not named LeBron is Phil
Knight
what's he doing on his phone number two
LeBron's sons are in
Michael Jordan's shoes
you son of a [__] you're gonna walk
home you little tour where are they
they're in the front row on their phones
in MJ shoes dude do they play ball are
they yes yeah he's good he's really good
the other one's not he's not LeBron but
he's good he's [__] good yes he's
really good yes but so they're on their
phones so my problem is they're on the
phones number two is that um they're in
Jordan's right and then my third caveat
there was I forget now and I'm trying to
draw this out but I had another problem
with this picture
oh geez this was the third quarter
they stopped the game
and they're in 13th Place they need this
win they lost they stopped the game for
I don't know 20 minutes as he gave a
speech and all [__] and then came on and
they lost what you think Jordan would
allow him to start never never that's
why Jordan's my number one you gotta
have that never [__] game in the
middle of it I've never heard of that
that's ridiculous and you know what else
was and uh there's a funny video out
there that's probably why Kareem Abdul
Japan and these guys are like was Jabbar
at this game oh yeah I had to he gave
him he gave him the ball
but they don't get along no they don't
like each other how do you know it's
just it's very well known they do not
like each other
wow
look at his finger Kareem's finger can I
yeah hold on what's going on there it's
the size of our dick that looks like an
uh a witch's cane that's incredible so
how about post post games it's a magical
finger that finger just that might put a
curse on him I'd be like why are you
pointing at me that's that thing why
does it look like a twig you'd find in
like hiking your finger is gonna cut
you're you're casting a spell on me with
that finger is your finger a turd
um and then you see his finger and it's
totally straight after yeah like whoa
what the [__] but but that Shaq was
doing the post game uh interviews and
then he goes LeBron goes LeBron who's
the best of all time and LeBron's like
you know man everyone's good he goes no
no stop it stop it tell us the truth who
is the best player to ever play
basketball he's like they're all great
just depends your shot goes no stop I'm
not taking that say it with your chest
tell us what you I know how you feel sit
and LeBron's like all right man I think
I can beat anybody in the world I'm the
best to ever do it and Shaq's like there
you go you say what you feel man and
what LeBron did and he's gone on record
saying that before but he he was like
you know he always says
I think Jordan said that previously go
you don't have to tell people you're the
greatest they'll tell you yeah but they
were saying this morning guarantee
because the uh Jordan plays golf every
morning Florida it's uh one of the uh
analysts was like I will guarantee right
now Jordan's on hole four and if someone
hey did you see LeBron that says yeah so
what do you think is on the dress all
the time he goes you know a day won't go
by without a doubt he goes with without
a doubt Jordan a day won't go by where
if you bring up LeBron and go I'm better
than it
every he was to this day he plays golf
every day on whatever Hall if you go hey
man what you think of LeBron I'm better
than him he goes you don't even answer
the question
he's just Savage he's he's the Savage of
all Savages now you know this what else
you know LeBron's the first active
billionaire playing basketball but you
know Jordan made I think what they say
like 90 million over his career yeah you
know he made more money this year alone
of selling Michael Jordan Brands they
ever got paid playing basketball he
makes some crazy amount off of every
shoe Nike sells like twelve dollars the
only Jordans okay but his son and his
daughter helped run it and then his this
year where he gets dicey his son is
dating Scottie Pippen's ex-wife no his
son is dating Scottie Pippins take that
in daddy that's so hot
well look at his ex-wife now Scotty
Doesn't Like MJ
well yeah but don't blame the man for
dating his ex-wife she's everybody
should date her yeah I mean he should
shave his [__] beard but yeah so
that's Michael's son yep huh did he he
played D1 ball I think uh UCF wasn't
very good but he's doing well in life
he's running his dad's brand things are
going well [__] down her he's doing
well yeah he's doing very Scottie
Pippen's like excuse me if you have all
the people out of all the people they
all look like everybody looks the same
these women now with all this plastic
surgery every one of them looking really
new people all the women all these all
these professional professional yeah you
mean they're all hot they all look like
Kim Kardashian or a variational her and
Kim used to be hot but same same I will
get two into the details but it's all
like it's like a package deal it's a
starter kit the circuit of Awesomeness
Bryant my girl looks like them God bless
her I love her yeah did you see the
video I sent your wife last night for
what she said
I sent her up last night without me
knowing yeah yeah well I was on the
phone with you for a while because we
have our night like why walk in the
house and I put my phone away yeah and
then last night because you and I were
dealing with business stuff I was on the
phone all night with you and then my
agents all night to like 9 30 and she's
like are you done I was like I'm done
let's watch our show she's like [__] You
I'm tired I'm like all right what show I
knew I did stream ownership I went
you're right that's on me what I'm sorry
to figure things out so we can pay our
mortgage number still I hope
no
[__] no that's why she didn't show me oh
no hey take ownership right I do there
you go there you go again [__] up
it's Prime
just saying hi it's been a long time
I know Brennan probably talks about me
constantly but you but you haven't seen
my face in a while and let's be honest
I'm looking pretty damn good all right
just thought I'd leave you a message
don't tell Brandon
she loves you she would have told me if
you sent that that's why I was like what
the [__] is going on she ain't tell me
[__] uh we're watching um oh that's her
old number then that's her old number
[__] some random vaccine ladies like who
the [__] uh we ran out of shows our
show's uh is the the last of us but
that's once every Sunday so we're
re-watching uh True Detective season one
with Woody Harrelson would you ever
watch that foreign film like uh
subtitles yeah no
because nah well if it's good enough
because especially if it's on World War
you really want to see how uh like an
intelligence agency works oh you told me
this the bureau like I don't know if my
girl will be into but I watch it and I
go yeah maybe not but I watch it and I
and I'm like I can't believe like I
can't believe
how ingenious some of this [__] is like
how they track people like I love when
people think that they're not being like
if if an intelligence agency from a
country whether it's France CIA or or
China wherever it might be Mossad if
they want to know everything about you
if they want to capture if they want
itself so done GPS
things you've never even thought about
you don't say what people that commit a
crime and they think they can get away
with it the best like I robbed the bank
or I killed somebody and then I got rid
of the body and the FBI comes along and
goes yeah they just you get these
Behavioral Science and they're like
that's adorable you thought oh this is
adorable you see what the deal is dude
is that we're black belts and you just
took a class well how about our buddy
who's in the dark arts I went I sat down
with them I was like you can't be with
me if you can keep doing stuff and he
was like you know not taking ownership
the extreme motion about it let me just
say something so you know you're a small
fish in the game you think you're
smarter than the Central Intelligence
Agency yeah or the FBI do you know how
smart those guys are it's all they do
some have Harvard degrees did you go to
college no High School cool Hey listen
trust me if you think you're gonna
outsmart them I'm here telling you yeah
at this coffee shop yeah it ain't
happening no no you're a duck flapping
around in the water I'm like the only
reason you're alive that they the
crocodile just hasn't seen you yet or
they've seen you but you're not tasty
enough that's right but when they decide
they're hungry and they're just bored
they're gonna swim do a lap right now
they're doing a lap yeah trust me yeah
they're probably recording what we're
talking about right now at this guy I
talked to a guy who was uh a terrorist
Hunter he was a very special operator in
the military one of those tip of the
spirit such a cool job and he's going
through like the way they would find
guys and I and I I finally I'm listening
I go like they were talking about how
Isis why you don't hear about Isis
anymore like you get the the American
Military after you you get like Delta
SEAL Team Six round Branch from the CIA
all these other task forces like like I
I'm listening and I go I go what the
[__] like what do you do hide in the
cave he goes you die that's what you do
don't die oh when the boys get a cent
the American troops Jesus the few the
proud the maturines yes well I told you
when I was in Afghanistan I was talking
to this Commander of men this Millet
this uh he was like a sergeant in the in
the Army infantry or some he was like a
master sergeant like a like a real man
big man in scene combat lost man under
his command a real man 45 years old
built like a [__] brick [__] house I
was already kind of like so impressed
with this guy yeah you want to [__] him
yeah and then I see I see uh I see the
dark side walk by me I see just a bunch
of these dudes these Tim Kennedy Guys
these you know these guys who are just
like
and they're not wearing uniforms
but they're bristling with exotic
weaponry and they don't have any ID and
they're not saluting anybody but they're
just walking until you cross the in the
airport but this is a little uh military
yeah and they get into a tiny plane with
no seats and I'm looking at these guys
and I was like who the [__] are they the
guy next to me goes the commander of men
he goes That's The Dark Side brother
that's the dark side you want to be them
now I believe those guys as I've done
some work on no they're going to do
charity worker they they were probably
they're a military wing of something
called the CIA or something like that
yeah and they okay kiss my dick they got
a beat on somebody or on a group that
was up to no good up to mischief and
they they came in to do some neutrals
now did they just go in and talk them
say stop doing that they came in and
dropped off uh a package they dropped
off a package with a condom a candy bar
made by the USSA that's right that
sparklers and a bomb for their mouth
okay that should get to me rock hard for
our American troops yeah badasses yeah
very very out to show called I think
it's called taking the stand it's so
[__] good taking this because it's
people that are accused of something and
they gotta they gotta it shows the trial
like obviously not the full-length trial
but it shows like them going through it
so see that lady right there that old
lady with the she looks like my uh
parrot fish with the cheeks yeah so she
I think I might know who she is bro can
I take a guess go ahead I think she
looks like a nice old lady but wish did
she kill a lot of people did she have a
house no okay no it's something else all
right she used to write uh like love
novels okay and she used to write a
thing and she wrote a whole Memoir
called how to kill your husband get away
with it right several years ago
well her husband who was a chef shows up
to work in the morning it's 9 A.M it's
like in Portland right 9 A.M and uh gets
shot in the chest Point blanking the
chest and shot in the back
she takes a stand and they go well this
is this is weird because we found nine
millimeter and uh you wrote a whole book
on how to kill your husband get away
with it she goes it's insane I can't
believe this you guys are accusing me of
this that's just you know that's fiction
and that's not real blah blah blah and
they go right right right well there's
cameras everywhere because it's downtown
Portland we have at uh 904 when it's
dropped off at 9 9 A.M your SUV SUV
coming by there she was that's not me it
was interesting well you have a dent on
the side of your car that's your exact
car the exact Dent she goes weird that's
strange that is strange and so she's
taking a stand and they her uh the her
defense team goes don't take the stand
doesn't go well for anybody but she
thought she could outsmart everyone she
goes no I'm gonna do it so the
prosecutors go fantastic go on go on up
there you don't realize how good they
are so they go well we have your car do
this and you do it for a living you've
seen it doing it so they take her
through the whole thing to get her to
lie you know to see how she but she was
so confident she could outmaneuver
everyone and she go and they go well so
you're saying that you weren't at that
location she goes no I was she changed
it on the thing is shooting flips she
goes no actually I do recall I was doing
that there you go so you make your car's
issues my car was there I take a drive
around in the mornings I write okay I
just went by his work they go
interesting five minutes after he died
your car goes by you don't think that's
a coincidence she goes it's crazy yeah
and I can see how you think that yeah
it's very strange and she goes here's
the thing I have this thing where I just
I black out
and I was driving I blacked out I don't
know what I did and she thought she was
gonna be able to get away with that
that's your uh and they went with the
car would have crash
with the car would have cracked I
blacked out she goes well no I I'm still
functioning but my brain so I don't I
just passed by there that's why I didn't
remember it
and they all cool and they go well we
went through your search history that's
what everyone was busted with you went
through search history you have a search
history on there on how to build a nine
millimeter gun
and she goes I was researched for my
book
and they go really she goes yes research
on my book and they go okay well the gun
we found is the same casings
that we found the murder site there's a
lot of pieces she's so [__] see ya so
but she thought well I bought that gun
just for research they go cool well we
looked at more into it and on Amazon you
bought the top the what is it the you
know you talk back that slide slide you
bought the slide and then replaced it so
we couldn't tell it was that gun oh she
went to prison for life well of course
you did for life you bought it on Amazon
yeah they're cameras everywhere you
don't know are you living in the 18 it's
40. it's my favorite thing because they
think they can get it but I love this
about life so one of the reasons that if
I'm if I'm so Dylan Dennis walks in here
whatever and I I start to roll with him
I do Jiu Jitsu now you can predict
um how much money do you put on him to
tap me out I'll call my business guy and
say how much money all the money right
all the money yeah now why is that
because why don't I stand a chance Dylan
Dennis has been there a thousand times
so everything I do he's ahead of me it's
like like why you can never beat a chess
master every move you make he sees it a
thousand times everything in life is
that way right everything in life is
that way and that's one of the things I
actually love about practice and getting
really good at something you think you
know you can't take do something for a
month no shortcut yeah and the same
thing goes with [__] everything
especially crime those [__]
have been doing this for a long time
they've also studied human behavior they
can see your Tendencies it's like
quarterbacks you were telling me one
time quarterbacks they they'll look at
your family history they'll look at your
emotional Tendencies everything they
look at everything so those offensive
coordinators I mean those defensive
coordinators that on the other side
they're looking at that [__] too
everything they know how to force you in
the pocket if you can't throw they're
not what's crazy with this old bat and
she gets accused of all this and then
they interview and she's like it's in
they get the wrong person well she's a
social person okay that's a sociopath
okay yeah there are people that are that
are oh and then this where she got bust
they go uh 30 minutes after you found
out he's dead you called the insurance
to see how much money you were going to
get that doesn't sound like some uh
grieving wife would do just not to be
worried about finances he's the
breadwinner they go we get that in all
our years of exploring the [__] never
has a person who didn't commit the
murder called Insurance see how much
money they were gonna get she's a [__]
first of all she's dumb as [__] I call
it cheap do you know what they say about
uh sociopaths what the number one
emotion is when they get convicted do
you know what the number denial anger
surprise
like they can't believe that actually
they like they're like what me
for shoes they said she was going around
town bragging how she's gonna get out of
it God
isn't it not it's such a good show
though I gotta watch it yeah it's great
um and these people go away oh yeah for
like life yeah but they they flipped the
script because I need high stakes
there's somebody who she robbed this
guy's baby mama
I don't give a [__] yeah I need life on
the line man although I really hate con
men I hate people that steal with scams
scammers make me I I you wouldn't want
Jamaicans right now I'm talking about
all this Jamaicans there are a lot of
social bats online you know Jordan
Peterson was talking about in a
psychologist psychologist they were they
were studying the fact that social media
has has allowed a lot of people that get
off on because they can hide they get
off on destruction say this they like to
see it's called cause suffering
um yeah there's there's this I there's
this they they get sadistic but but it's
not just people who you think it can be
a lot of people that you'd be so amazed
at it could be a kindergarten teacher
it's a doctor sure there's that size
they can hide yeah you're gonna have to
be out there a lot of people that can be
like I'm gonna [__] with you they do
that they're just like and Jordan
Peterson was talking about how uh
like a lot of the scams like they're
getting old people you know like even my
mom almost got scammed she's like oh
yeah you know they stole my identity I'm
like all of them she's like uh I Apple
sent me this email I'm like Mama click
on the thing it's like at
xx9077.com I'm like that's not real you
imagine people doing that like oh people
they go we just need 10 000 and then
we're gonna give you a hundred thousand
back in a month but I do that I drag
them I bring them I better say that that
yeah you're just wasting your time
though right he was in Jamaica I just
kept I kept saying I sent the money
where where what okay but are you saying
and I I kept them on for a full [__]
day I had them running well it's like
that cat scam right I was looking for
those cats and then the guy was like we
said that whatever was like two grand
whatever right but then he was like yeah
but he was like hey we need a special
crate and you just pay for it up front
they'll send the money back and then a
little Spidey scent went ding oh you got
scam
[__] you got I told my grandma don't
save any money we're not getting our
money back we got scammed she's like no
I'm like do not communicate with them
they got you they got you and I slapped
her good skin what I slapped her what
two grand okay I'd love to see you try
to slap Joanna she'd [__] count she
would [__] me up it wouldn't be a Chris
Rock Will Smith thing I'd have my hands
she would [__] oh dude a handful hand
Savage yeah she wasn't strong strong
she'd give it back good but good that
knocked her out but yeah sure
no I like your I like no we're having
fun on the show right yeah sure yeah I
knocked you and her out right right
that's the world we live in right hey
right because that's it's just business
that's a lot of physical it's just
physics right now and I want to and that
shows you how far I've come in therapy
right it's my anger can you tell I'm
angry I'm fuming inside but outside
outside you're a professional I'm a
sweet and sour Evan I'm between sour
candy from Black Rifle coffee I did the
podcast with him and he he was uh Green
Beret and he said there Comes A Time In
in uh War when the Only Rule and law is
physics it's the law of physics like
that's what's keeping you alive that's
what is winning battle bro did you
listen to uh uh they're on that um
that political podcast they want to
Independent on their own they're on
Rogan they're just on Rogan I always
forget their names stay hard and I
forget the girls down to it but Crystal
and Segar Crystal and Sega dude it'll
scare the [__] you about the Ukrainian
War how if we keep going we're headed
towards I know some bad [__] it'll
stretch out well it'll stretch out
because Russia is fighting a lot of
people believe Russia is fighting for
their existential existence Russia is
already has major problems but Russia
the reason Russia was always going to
invade Ukraine is it needs these the
ports it needs to control the ports of
entry on the on the western side of
Ukraine on the Eastern side but did you
we've sent more money to them than we've
ever sent during that yeah
West knows that Russia is not going to
stop the West knows that Russia is not
going to stop but then that that that
singer say is this singer I'll look it
up right now but he goes he goes well
people go well Ukraine's winning he goes
I can go back to the Civil War when the
you know know the Confederate looked
like they were going early on World War
one in the first year it would have
looked like the not you know the Germans
were going to win World War II it looked
like the Nazis were going to win he goes
so your excuse to go well Ukraine's
winning they're going to do this you
know war is long so for you guys win
this way the Russians fight him crystal
ball and Sager they're so good this is
how the Russians fight they throw all
the bodies all the bodies so many people
die so and then they recalibrate lose
500 000 don't give a [__] they don't and
so everybody's going to war and it's
going to die now there is a point where
they which there is a school of thought
that says you can make it so costly on
them on their economy and on their young
Workforce they don't care that they
actually will have to stop they don't
care but well we're not there yet well
there's the war's so long they don't
care but they'll be forced they'll be
forced ultimately to what would look at
the collapse of their economy so the way
Ronald Reagan said about about this the
arms race he said we are going to we are
going to if they build one rocket we're
going to build two
and we are going to keep doing this and
we're gonna we're gonna have force them
to keep up with our economy we're going
to force them to keep up with our arms
race and what's going to happen is their
economy is going to collapse which is
exactly what they did not only the
economy collapsed their system collapsed
and the Soviet Union fell apart because
they couldn't do it but that's and that
would be the theory here because all
that crystal said to said it best she
goes but at what cost is it going to
cost the Americans when we gotta start
looking out for ourselves to keep
sending all this money that's right you
got what costs to us but America before
we go hold on we're going to get in
World War Three here we keep going
because if we keep sending these
missiles and planes and that's what
[__] Russia Russians go hold on now you
guys are an enemy right well so so there
are a couple things one is the Americans
are practicing the Americans have a
great Battleground to to see how their
Weaponry does
so it's a testing ground so there's that
secondly all of Europe is doing that as
well thirdly though there is a way that
we know that there's a red line with
Putin which says it you you NATO could
destroy the entire Russian army in a
long weekend yeah they know that so so
put a holiday weekend yeah Martin Luther
King on Monday yes but Putin knows Putin
has made it clear that there is a Red
Line in the Sand you guys start
decimating all our troops and we will
use the Tactical nuke or at least got
those threats that new count so there
were you want the underground no there's
this Balancing Act we're doing which is
like how much can we how much can we
make it costly to the what we want to do
the big part is that we're saying we're
going to bleed the Russians on the
Ukrainian Battlefield hundreds of
thousands Russians it's going to be at
least half a million or more the
alternative the alternative is that
they're going to use their mercenaries
to come in and anyone in those towns the
refugees all leave anyone in those towns
is shot on site it doesn't matter who
they are because they're considered
combatants and so the the we don't know
how many ukrainians have been killed but
it's it could be as much horrible
it is horrible for everyone all those
young Russian dudes they don't want to
fight there no in the winter right now
in in February in Ukraine oh my God see
what the weather is in Ukraine right now
see what the [__] weather is right
now uh I'll tell you cold as [__] 17
degrees now that's a good time
1 a.m there well it gets up to 30
six on Thursday that's fun when you're
dying hey fellas enjoy fighting in the
rain on Monday
well you know you know you know about
the mud in Ukraine it's the mud season
so there's crazy mud that you're stuck
in
I feel so bad for them the whole thing's
terrible what's going on seriously let's
change the subject's so dark yeah but
they were a good listen I've been you
know I was offered I told you this I was
offered an opportunity to go to Ukraine
recently shoot uh with Matthew
McConaughey shoot one of my episodes of
best of where I would interview oh
absolutely not bro all the top brass no
the Ukraine military no no and I said
and I said yeah we get in there and
sneaking yeah you got to drive a long
way we can't find the Ukraine because no
fly zone right now because they're in
war so you'd have to fly in somewhere
else then drive in yeah now hey hold on
let me just spill ideas There For You
YouTube so oh well no hey I know real
quick I'm just I'm just spitballing I
use it you're gonna play an interview
Ukrainian military in a war zone
for YouTube show the answer is no sir
now here's the thing also now if they
offer daddy 10 mil I'll do well my wife
was holding my baby and she goes excuse
me excuse me I was like okay never mind
like she wouldn't even you're doing for
the gram so you can post on Instagram no
I would have said you take a selfie with
Russian for the show that's the
stupidest idea heard it it's also here's
the other thing that you have to
understand you just drive down to South
Central and yelled them you got to go
somewhere you got to go somewhere you
got to get in the car and drive or you
got to do something right now now
um you're gonna go there with other
people who have things to do there
do you think that do you think there's a
chance that the I'm just gonna ask you
can trust all those people no no I'm
gonna ask do you think there's a chance
that the Russians might be looking for
that kind of thing yeah and now now if
they think that you're allied with
the Ukraine's in some way do you think
there's a chance they might well they're
going to rape you they might take
umbrage with that yeah they don't take
complete ownership and rape you
and you're going to film that I am yeah
dude you want views or not you flew all
that way
your mustache is off
my son to help me shave today look at
this side look at this yeah man Escapes
in the stupidest that I want to do it
your mustache looks a little is it
Hitler it looks a little pedophiley oh
man
um I was going to say if you if you if
you took just a little bit more off
you'd be it's gonna get Hitler you got
to be careful yeah yeah it's got to do
that's why I don't touch you know what
Daddy's running late even though Brian
sent the wrong address so I could have
done it but we're just gonna roll like
this yeah
because it's too late right I could have
fixed it if I knew that you're gonna
[__] up and not take ownership yeah
complete ownership I uh so now the
slide's all [__] up hopefully it grows
out
soon because we're doing fight playing
on Rogan that's not a big audience at
all no nobody's gonna see that I uh I
gotta I got into a fun um text exchange
with Will Sasso
and I said uh nice guy on the planet
yeah and I I said hey uh you know I
haven't heard from them in a little bit
and I was like hey man my phone's been
kind of jammed up so you're probably
trying to text me and just might blow me
up so many texts that like your text
might have gotten pushed out of the
algorithm or something
and he just I just get back
I'm on the toilet I've been on the
toilet
she's so stupid
I thought you just respond back okay
no he's [__] all right Jane give us
some current events buddy
all right
I'm trying to find the exchange
can you do that first bye that's all
right whenever we read text they bomb
here
generally send this to you I don't know
if this is funny and if it's not a woman
hey look at me it won't be he sent he
sent me this he sent me this
um maybe you just show us like a bear he
just send us a video of like a bear
what everybody just said like just
random videos or be like a guy fisting
another guy but he said well can you not
send those stuff and he just wrote my
[__] chops in cold weather weather if
exposed I go no you're missing my point
and then I just got this video I just
sent you
I'll tell you you don't want to be on a
text thread with with his uh Mike
catherwood
coming out of his butt I mean I know I
had to tell him like Hey can you take me
off this I know he was like dude come on
seriously take me off he's living on a
farm somewhere he's in Austin
he's crushing it he's great it's not
coming in yet bro let's just hold on
until I see it then yeah
uh did you guys see this this is in
Phoenix a skyscraper some uh activists I
guess anti-abortion activists hell yeah
do everyone stop having abortions so
he's gonna climb up don't worry I'm
gonna go oh but no this is crazy look
how high this guy dude look how high
this guy got I'll show you he must be a
professional he's definitely a climber
and he did it that way that you do this
against like two and he spread the yeah
no no nothing
I don't get it this is for abortion
man he's uh I guess you just did
everyone stop having babies that's a
skyscraper oh it makes my [__] Tingle
look at this
so I made three you can hear people
cheering that was part of his team
arrested yeah he jumped off the building
oh my God you'll see him talk here
[Music]
uh We Are Climbing today to raise money
for a woman named Hope who is 22 weeks
pregnant
and uh we just want to help her she has
some disabilities we want to help her
choose life so please if you guys want
to donate go over to let them live.org
choose Live Crew down there have a baby
session going on there
for Life Wolverine and a bunch of
friends there's eight people
at least he's putting his money where
his mouth is but holy [__] that's the
guy right there he's doing what he
thinks his Heroes that's just a young
man it's just I mean hopefully they
raise money though hopefully yeah you
don't waste but that's a guy who's just
dying to climb a skyscraper yeah
like pregnant
I was like hey dude you should climb for
her he's like [__] yeah he would climb
for Ukraine he would cry like whatever
there he wants to climb yeah he wants to
[__] him he didn't get any water though
this is what he's complaining about I
should climb for his teeth I can see why
a lion will bear
brings uh water with him
but I just got troop it out everything's
going good though he's a badass
he's crazy yeah he's crazy some people
are built out they have something so
nervous oh my my my nuts are up into my
stomach the [__] good luck getting
in there but let me see it okay let me
make sure let me loosen things there's
spots oh you're awesome like Spots
You're puckered
good luck I'll go like this enjoy this
you like Dalmations
say that again you like Dalmatians
psoriasis let's hear one more time
Dalmatians I'll give you another chance
fourth time think about it what is it
you're you English your first language I
need no no no CeCe see Bueno Bueno I
know I'm not from this country talking
about the dog with spots no what do you
think what are you talking about save
for me so I can hear it let me see what
if your thing is when you said Dalmation
because you said you have spots
Dalmatians that's what I said how do you
say it Dalmatian Dalmatian that's what I
said don't say Dalmatian oh you're
talking about the dog that'd be
animation you're confusing you're mixing
animation about Dalmatian was animated
it'd be a domination
right dude I'm thinking of a doll right
that's animated got it it's a Dalmatian
got it my bad you talking about the dog
that's right no no oh this that would
make sense the reference makes sense
I'm talking about a spotted doll what
was that animated so the dalmatian what
Dalmatian there you go yeah that's good
and and what is that car that's really
expensive made in England by hand
Bentley what's the other one
uh not a Royals Royce
Rolls-Royce yeah not that not a Royals
right there you go
well dude you're not in the Club Royale
like you probably call it cheeseburger
like the rest of the sheep call it a
cheeseburger yeah I call it a Royale
with cheese got it I see so you're
you're adding in other languages you
know what it is it's for the
one percent it's for the Europeans no I
talked hey I talk for the one percent no
no I know I appreciate it Royals Royce
your royalty a Dalmatian this is a video
I'm gonna leave for people whenever um
they say something stupid and I just
don't have a rebuttal to it let me see
it oh you finally get the video
boom Boosh
do you think you get CT from that uh I
don't know I don't think it Compares wow
don't [__] with a bull
I don't know how he finds these videos
just randomly
what else you got Jen let's see real
quick
um so I guess post Malone was making
some headlines because he lost a ton of
weight people thought he was on drugs
it's not even the last time he moves the
way he moves well he's like he's like
maybe he's just insecure when he sings
but like he first of all he's singing
like this I'm like rubbing his body yeah
it looks like he's tweaking out a little
bit I'll play it but I'll turn the Audio
I love how he's on on wearing shorts
yeah I like it too
so then this is the beginning he puts
his hands in his shirt
the boy can sing though yeah because he
can
and then I'll fast forward to here when
he moves more he had some bad luck
because he went to Zach back in his
Haunted Mansion haunted thing see see
there he's doing this
nah he's fine hold on look he's it's
he's doing this and he's put his hands
behind his back [__] yeah he might just
be high on yeah Molly no that's the
thing is he's denying that he was on
drugs so people thought he was either on
drugs what could have been which could
have been Molly or cocaine or whatever
but uh he's you know he's just in the
moment doing his song he might just be
taken care of himself that's what I did
when I lost weight he's a good looking
guy he he's he but the unique looking
guy yeah the face time what makes it if
I had his money I'd have faith yeah I
did you would on the engine I think we
all would if this show gets other than
you Brian if this show gets a little
bigger the three of us are getting
faceted I would totally get it if I
don't have to everywhere why I think
they're cool I mean you think they're
not not all cool no just certain ones
that have me yeah I love them too I have
meaning I love when chicks have them let
me hear what you call me put on your
face
on this new
ridiculous Trend hey as the kids say put
them on game channel
give me tell me chin what [__] face
whatever reminder I need if I look in
the mirror oh what is that reminder okay
when I don't anymore
I would want here damn yeah a little
something oh I'd love to get something
here I want I want a tattoo that goes up
to here
bro some Chinese letters or some [__]
well what would you happen bro I could
get a big flowerhorn fish on my neck
yeah that's what you should get you
should have a real flowerhorn fish and
we get a Dalmatians
if this fat flat horn no if this diet
just tape it to your dumb thick neck
make sure you get a big roll because you
have a very thick neck and let it flop
around in your dump oh that'd be cool
that'd be sick
I'll tell you what if this if this diet
in the medication I take for psoriasis
doesn't help and I have two spots I'm
gonna tattoo my entire body except for
my face yeah you're gonna test because
you can't see it yeah it's a good call I
don't know if you can tattoo just relax
give yourself some time yeah I know it
takes forever they say it takes patience
yeah it's already getting better it's
God teaching you it's God teaching you
how weird is it that you have psoriasis
now this is so crazy oh it's so funny
I'm slowly turning to you my dick's
bigger what else you got chin
me dead
Liam Neeson did an interview with Men's
Health Magazine and then he mentioned
how he doesn't like these he sounds like
Brian he just sounds old I can't stand
that to me is like a bar fight I know
the practitioners are like Oh no you're
wrong the monster training we do why
don't you just grab a beer bottle and
hit the other guy over the head that's
the stage of the UFC which is
interesting I hate it the little
leprechaun Conor McGregor he gets
Ireland a bad name I know it's fit and I
had my room for that but I can't take it
well what does it help get what he said
that's how Connor responded well what
doesn't help to defend the UFC is Dana
promoting the slap that's why it's
interesting that's right he's like
that's why everyone's like oh you're off
on this well I was like Daniel said DMC
back 10 years that's right not with the
hardcore is we respect the sport with
the common fan like wait UFC's Bruins
slap Fight League like how Bush league
is this that's why I was like it's such
a terrible look you've done all this
work to move the ball forward you've
done a great job and now you've
completely washed it away we're remember
dick Chinese wouldn't allowed because
it's human [__] fighting when you do the
slap Fight League that's what they're
talking about that is not a real sport
that is just CT at its finest I can't
believe in 2023 that thing's you and I
like wild [__] and I'll watch it but
that I also watch beheadings I'm world
star you know but that doesn't mean it's
a sport and you don't want to be
Associated like the NFL would you
imagine the NFL started [__]
promoting it's actually the most
surprising thing do you have any intel
on that like why did they decide to do
that it's not going to make money who's
watching that [__] no one and the
ratings are awful it's also like you
know what Dana's rebuttal was what we're
being the NFL and UFC on Tick Tock views
I'm like yeah because so outlandish
well it's spectacles yes that's all
there's no longevity there
what else you got you one more mma-ish
related stuff okay it is m-related so
Dana White we talked about this on shop
show uh but he's doubling down on the
reason why people don't understand that
he's actually promoting UFC 284 when
people were saying that he's promoting
slot fighting more than that now I'll
defend Dana here a little bit he is by
far pushing slap fight more than
anything else going on in his life which
is just ridiculous
but also that will be I think it's
trending to be bigger than Conor's
fights they give me top three biggest
pay-per-views biggest gate of all time
so they're doing something right with
the promotion maybe that doesn't need
promotions so he's like hey that thing's
already sold out it's trending the right
direction let's focus on this [__]
slap Fight League so there's that but
then also he says that but he also goes
I think it's whoever's translating
because makshev I've spoke to him he
didn't say that he's not like what the
[__] he's saying it's the translator
may seem like Mark Joe's like yeah
they're not promoting this right they're
not promote enough he goes it's the
translation
don't give a [__] right
I still think photography is going to
win right
what
Dalmatian
okay
I think this is a good podcast we turned
lemons into lemonade I still have rage
in my heart and I want to hurt you but
do my therapy complete ownership it's
gonna manifest extreme ownership skin
more spots that's fine yeah
made me tattoo my whole body what else
you got chin uh this one I thought was
super weird
this is Jill Biden uh kissing Kamala
Harris's husband on the lips on stage so
I'll show you real quick the clip
whoa apparently that's okay I don't know
apparently that's like a is he foreign
[Music]
now Brian I don't know how they're doing
politics that's to each its own if you
kiss my girl like that I would [__] you
up in my house with all the therapy I've
been doing I'm good baby I would [__]
you up dude if you kiss my girl with
those old you would try butterscotch
teeth you would try I got some tricks
that's fine
is it fine yeah I got some tricks you
would if I came in I walked the house
and went hey B where you see I went to
your wife went
watch this you what would you do would
you you would you'd go whoa relax I'd go
hey sweetheart it's good to see you man
I made you a video and you didn't see it
because I sent it to the wrong thing uh
I love what you did with the place
God that was gay all right um is that
too much yeah I feel sick really yeah
your old chapped lips on my drink did
you see how I just all right
no I got it around is he upstairs
it's so good to see you she's like yeah
he's dealing with the fish
oh my God no no no oh you're the spouse
yes suck it
don't put your hand on her lips
does this not weird it's so weird it's
so weird and everyone's just all good
with it it's these politicians Left
Right are all [__] weird dude they're
all out of their goddamn mind personal
question have you ever had have you ever
had a couple
friend
like if you're friends with a couple
yeah I don't know them that well yeah
and you get swinger vibes from them has
that ever happened to you no no no it
has not wish okay I wish just something
I'd be like I'm down sure
someone I'm like hey hey I'm not you
know I'm not weird like that but if you
don't know you do you want to in the
pool yeah Daddy jumping in or it's like
this or you're away because your wife
goes would you and you'd go I mean only
if you I'd like oh that's not my call
I'm gonna taste not Michael I'm gonna
take extreme ownership because if you
put me into it I'm in I mean don't stick
your finger in the cage because if I get
hold of that finger ain't letting go now
I'ma suck it dry you know I'm gonna tell
you this I'm gonna say first of all I if
you want to do this you can do this you
ever see what I do the rental car
[Applause]
you see why I do the exhaust on a rental
car
you're going to drive that
thing you're going to drive you're gonna
drive that thing oh that that is
that exhaust also your ass we get it can
you just stay metaphoricals you have to
go no I want to make sure you get it
yeah I get it because that exhaust your
anus okay
daddy gonna plug it up hey Daddy hey
yeah I know but did you have to say you
can use a metaphor hey like is there an
empty parking lot I'm gonna do some
donuts no I'm returning cars you have
some scuffs on it right that's better
there's going to be some scuffs on the
car I might do some donuts because the
Hood's great the hood great big tits
that's great you don't have to add the
big tits your hoods your chassis good
your chassis is good Thunder kids sure
but that exhaust we're going to swap
some paint though like in NASCAR when
you swap paint you touch oh no no we're
not swapping paint I'm a splatter paint
hey hey
I know I get it but you're so bad you
have to take the metaphor a step further
no no I just want to make sure I'm very
clear think about it no no I'm taking it
super clear extreme ownership here
that's like the single entender guy who
goes I'm gonna [__] you in the end and
by that I mean I'm gonna take my dick
and put it in your ass if you know what
I mean
you see I like that guy it's so clear
and precise that's extreme ownership
it's on the nose guy that's what I want
it's on the nose if we're gonna play
this game yeah and you know the rules
yeah because I'm going to tell you again
you want to do the rental car yeah
that's good I want to be very clear when
I rented movies from Blacklist when I
returned them
had some scarves well I didn't rewind
them all the way never rewind no Be Kind
Rewind I didn't listen to that the
rewind becomes terrible you like the
rental car yeah the exhaust exhaust yeah
the exhaust yeah
yeah usually
about stuff going out
I'll be very clear I'm go now exhaust
for exit only right so I guess you go
but now there might be some carbon
dioxide in the cabin so keep them
windows open if you know what I mean see
if they're gonna go I'm sorry I go oh
I'm talking about doing anal with your
wife
if you know what I mean if you know what
I mean
it's good oh is that clear if you know
what I mean I mean I'm a returner and
she's not gonna be the same
she's gonna have me on her brain there's
gonna be paint spots hey you don't mind
if I get a little the hood gets wet
right no we got it now okay you don't
mind we gotta I don't mind if I cover
the hooding okay
um
I quit
I take extreme ownership
one last one just sitting by fan I was
trying to first get me out of come town
get me out of [__] town right now what
man let's check the metaphors check out
this fish tank foreign
here's the back of the tank this is the
water that flushes and here's the front
of the tank and
it'll make the illusion oh they're not
actually in the water
but yeah they don't get freaked out at
all anymore they I did I will say they
did at first but yeah yeah they're
probably terrified that's still pretty
badass stress on a fish here's my
problem
I if I'm taking a hot [__] I can't see
the fish
yes I guess yeah but that doesn't look
good on top of it doesn't look good when
I get confused I'd [__] in the tank
there was a guy but [__] in the tank I
mean when you were younger there when in
there in high school there was always
somebody who took a [__] in that tank
it's called an upper decker you old [__]
upper decker is right
take an upper decker
listen guys if you like comedy and
you're into comedy you come to Edmonton
Canada comic strip February 23 24 25. I
got Nashville Tennessee Sandy's March
two three or four New York New York Sony
Hall March 11th West Nyack New York
Levity Live March 16 17 18. I am riding
up a storm and it will be funny and you
will laugh great we're sold out
hell yeah I'll be uh I'm in Naples next
weekend but this weekend uh shooting
food truck on Friday Saturday we hit the
fight campaign that's a Grogan companion
this is not on thick boy it's on JRE
YouTube then we'll be uploaded to
Spotify right after if you don't watch
it live you better listen watch it on
Spotify Joe Rogan Eddie Bravo Brian
Collin myself the original OG crew is
back for UFC 284 this Saturday live on
JRE YouTube and then go Spotify tour
wise Maple next week Naples Florida
Comedy Off The Hook Naples is Thursday
Friday Saturday and then Bakersfield is
one night February 23rd that's almost
sold out get your tickets can't at Joe's
Brea two shows one night only very
special guests Brea California bread
improv is March 3rd that's a Friday
because on the fourth we have a big
companion with jelly roll Rampage and a
very special guest that's March 4th on
thick boy YouTube and I'm Oklahoma City
Tacoma get your tickets at
f-a-t-k-z.com or thickboy.com
um if I could paint this out I can't
wait you'll see 284. bring my [__]
cash or hey I'm gonna treat you like a
rental car I've got some money on this
yeah I'm gonna treat you like a rental
car try you try you're an Oldsmobile you
try you're an old caddy you're an old
cat I'm an old an old caddy thanks guys
hi kids love you